it's great to welcome to the program
today Jonathan Hebert who's the author
of the new book critical thinking from
MIT press also the guy behind logic
check dotnet a website that checks not
just the facts but also the reasoning
behind the news of the day it's so great
to have you on Jonathan great to be on
David so what what is the sort of origin
of critical thinking as a discipline
does it come from some of those
philosophers that many of us were
introduced to in in freshman year of
college
is it older than that well it definitely
draws on those ancient disciplines
certainly philosophy particularly
Western philosophy the work of Aristotle
but also more modern disciplines such as
science particularly some of the early
science that was a discourse between you
know philosophers and sort of proto
scientists psychology more recently and
then most recently cognitive science so
actually critical thinking itself the
concept that there's a form of thinking
unique enough to be all called critical
distinct from intelligence and wisdom is
actually a 20th century concept the some
of the so we've seen you know what a
media literacy class can look like
teaching one to critically analyze media
messages critical thinking epistemology
there's a lot of material on the
internet is the reason that a lot of
this material is necessary that these
are not concepts that we intuitively
learn in the sense that at some point
you know a baby realizes that the circle
is not going to fit into the rectangular
pair that you know triangular peg or
whatever and it's an intuitive lesson
are the critical thinking skills that
you espouse and talked about in the book
are they not something humans
intuitively pick up well they're
definitely not are our intuitions
actually need to be disciplined which is
why you need struck to structure your
thinking in order to reason I think you
know science is a good example where
people have not historically always
thought scientifically that was
something
that was constructed and over centuries
really the discipline of thinking
scientifically sort of developed into a
norm I think critical thinking is much
more broad than that it's something that
you could apply not just a science but
to every subject but it's not something
that comes intuitively nor is it taught
I mean it used to be you know going back
to Roman times logic rhetoric those were
the cornerstones of the educational
curriculum right through modernity but
in modern times of course have many more
things to learn modern science history
cultures language which is great but I
think that meant that logic rhetoric
some of the critical thinking kind of
core foundational skills have been
crowded out in favor of new knowledge
and I think that's one of the reasons we
both lack the intuition but we're not
taught this in schools are we currently
sort of at a bad moment when it comes to
critical thinking skills in the
population at large I know we've been
tracking and to anti intellectual
movements certainly for a couple hundred
years with a pretty significant degree
of specificity but is there some sort of
like peak that we are now experiencing
or dearth maybe is the right word you
know I think there's there's not been
some Golden Age where everybody thought
critically and we've sort of fallen off
since then I mean this has always been a
set of skills that some people take on
some people don't some people may be
more naturally inclined towards thinking
reasonably than others or you have you
know what's very typical is people will
think critically about subjects like
their jobs right they'll make decisions
about you know you're a carpenter how to
cut a piece of wood you're computer
programmer you can think very logically
when you're writing code but we will not
apply it to things like political
decisions whom to vote for or even sort
of interpersonal decisions so I think
probably what makes this period more
nerve-wracking is that there are all
kinds of ways to support thinking poorly
you know critical thinking is kind of
thinking well there are less productive
ways of thinking you can
believe whatever you already believe you
know confirmation bias you could believe
whatever you're told
right just believe authority figures and
I think now that we have a new media
landscape particularly with social media
that allows us to isolate ourselves into
bubbles where we don't really even have
to listen to anybody we disagree with I
think a lot of the sort of toxic
politics and miscommunication we have is
a result of you know not so much that
people aren't internalizing the rules of
critical thinking I think just there's
there's more sources of bad premises I
guess around is the what is the
mechanism that is most effective at
disarming ones critical thinking
faculties I mean you sort of alluded in
a way personal life's the things and
political things as opposed to how a
wood worker may best cut a piece of wood
is it sort of having a personal stake
which which blinds us maybe to applying
the same type of critical thinking we
otherwise would I think that that
there's you know critical thinking
skills you know you you had your YouTube
channel where you cover many of the
logical skills that are vital to
critical thinking that's what's covered
in a lot of critical thinking courses
you might take in college and there's a
lot of material on the internet on logic
and fallacies and those sorts of things
so that's the sort of knowledge you need
but then you need the skills to use that
knowledge in other words if we're
talking about logic for this example you
need to put those skills to use but put
the logical principles to use a lot in
lots of situations in your work in your
school in your life yeah and you need to
sort of favor thinking reasonably
thinking logically over other forms of
reasoning such as just believing what
you've already believed but then there's
a whole group of dispositions you know
you have to want to apply logic to
things that might make you uncomfortable
like examining your own beliefs for
example and I think that without all
three pieces without the knowledge the
skills and the dispositions you can't
really be think of yourself as a
critical thinker so I'd say situations
where people you know are very skilled
thinkers in certain parts that are
but turn off reason when it comes up to
other factors that's a form of sort of
not thinking critically in terms of not
exercising proper critical thinking
dispositions yeah so you can't teach
someone to want to examine their own
beliefs right I mean so it's you could
maybe encourage someone but it's not a
teachable skill in the same way that
identifying fallacies would be I think
it's not teachable except that you can
learn about the sort of flaws in the
human makeup that are non cognitive
right some of them are you know we could
be led by emotions or instincts right
those can overwhelm reason and also you
know there's cognitive biases there's
been a whole cottage industry of people
writing about confirmation bias and
anchoring bias and all these various
sort of you know flaws and our reasoning
so I think you can learn about the human
minds makeup and understand that we are
all susceptible to flawed thinking and
therefore we shouldn't assume we are
always right but I think in terms of
dispositions that would follow the
category of kind of morals education you
know that these are intellectual virtues
right open-mindedness faith and reason
intellectual humility and I think you
can learn those the same way you learn
other moral principles by example
example if you're your household
if these sort of intellectual virtues
are practiced then you'll tend to likely
internalize them if you live in a
household with dogmatic politics for
example or a place where fundamental
beliefs are never questioned then you
will learn that you will learn that
right you'll learn not to question
beliefs so I think they can be learned
it's sort of like behaviors you know any
sort of ethical behavior you'll learn
them over time when it comes to to make
this really concrete given the subject
matter of this program when it comes to
political messages and material that we
get through corporate media and mass
media what would you say are the one or
two sort of lowest hanging fruit in
terms of the principles that if more
frequently applied would lead
far more informed people so like one
that I might look at would be just
understanding correlation versus
causation right with coronavirus people
who get really sick tend to have lower
vitamin D levels is that a causation or
is that a correlation explained by
something else the economy did well
after something happened with taxes did
it do well because of that or are they
both impact right so that would be one
that I would maybe consider but I'm
curious what you would think about is
the the most important lowest hanging
fruit that would most help consumers of
political news well I think you know
correlation versus causation you know
much like the difference between
deductive and inductive reasoning and
many of the topics that kind of going to
be in critical thinker those are all
vital and I think the good news is one
can learn what they are and how to use
them relatively quickly I mean I think
your videos were three to five minutes
on each of these topics I did a program
called critical voter that sort of
taught much of the same material I would
know surprised how easy it is to learn
those things so I think certainly you
know the three things I would recommend
is one you know learn those things
because it doesn't take that much time
but I think you know if you want the
low-hanging fruit the things to do would
be one to practice them to use them as
much as possible critical thinking is
really a skill it's kind of like playing
the piano or being good at a sport right
the more you do it the better you get
there's one researcher who thinks
critical thinking is like you know a
sport or an instrument it takes 10,000
hours to get really good at it so I'd
say because the knowledge and the
techniques are relatively easy to pick
up it's just a question of how much you
dedicate to practicing them and then I
guess the other piece I'd say the lowest
hanging fruit even though it might be
the most difficult is shared ability you
know being charitable to opinions
especially those you don't agree with I
think show you did last week you refer
to steel Manning and argument which as
opposed to straw Manning an argument
naturally a reflection of the principle
of charity right you should try to
address the strongest version of an
opponent's argument rather than
attacking one flaw at or coming up with
a weak version or a parody and that's
relatively easy to do when it's your own
arguments you're looking to sort of
strengthen I think the hardest part is
to treat opposing arguments treating
arguments from people who you
fundamentally disagree with in a
charitable fashion but I think a lot of
intellectual virtues kind of derive from
that spirit of charity in the limited
time we have is there one specific
example that you've seen be one of the
most difficult beliefs or areas of
subject matter for people to really
think critically about well the two big
ones obviously politics and religion
right because these at both are
fundamentally about our identity and I
think certainly is religion sort of
fades as a foundation of identity our
sort of political identities take on
many qualities that were once sort of
you see and religious-based conflicts
you know kind of over the level of
heated nests so I would say you know the
understanding that any argument based on
somebody's identity is going to be have
to treat and be treated very sensitively
right because nobody ever changed their
mind about a belief fundamental or
identity because they lost in arguments
right nobody changed their mind because
they lost an argument on Twitter for
example but but even sort of lost you
know some more civilized argument right
that might crack the ice that might sort
of get you thinking oh maybe there's
some things I don't know or maybe some
of the things I believe I should
question but changing your mind changing
beliefs about something that's very very
personal to you is something that leaves
you very vulnerable so I think if if we
want to change the minds of others which
obviously you know your program and and
other media programs like it are looking
to do you should sort of do what you can
to empathize with those who disagree
with try to get into their heads try to
understand what they're thinking and
exercise I often challenge people on is
you know think about what arguments
would get you to change your mind about
something that you strongly believe in
and that'll get you to sort of
understand
the difficulty of such a situation and
once you could appreciate it then I
think you might be in a better position
to address opponents sort of address
people who you disagree with in a more
empathetic and anything ultimately
potentially more successful way the book
is critical thinking we've been speaking
with the author Jonathan Hebert whose
work you can also find at logic check
dotnet Jonathan really appreciate your
time and it's been a pleasure having you
oh thank you and thanks for all your
work as well